hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that was played yesterday in
chess.com open bullet
championship and it was suggested to me
on twitter by a user named
rimbo so thank you for that i doubt i
would have found it myself
and it would really be a shame if you
guys didn't see it it's uh
so good that it could be played in any
time format and
uh bear in mind that this is a bullet
game but not the actual bullet uh
it's a one plus one so every move they
make uh they get a one second increment
uh so without further ado let's check it
out and let's see what
this uh well uh position in the in the
thumbnail is all about
uh alireza furuja uh with the white
pieces opens with
d4 or or does he no he doesn't
i don't know what's wrong with the
interface uh
for the past few days but it seems to be
lagging okay so furuga opens with the d4
knight f6 by hikaru and knight to f3 uh
we have e6
e3 and adjust the d5 so just a normal
coal system here
uh b3 by ferruja preparing to fianchetto
the dark square bishop and the c5 by
hikaru striking in the center
uh bishop to b2 and hikaru trades once
we have captures captures and
knife the c6 so this has all been played
before a lot of games in the
uh database with uh this this exact move
order
knight b to d2 uh and now bishop to d6
both players now preparing to castle
their kings bishop to d3
and now both hikaru and furuja castle
and here bishop to d7 so just continuing
development
and hikaru gets his knight into the
center 95 and
this is always uh well most of the times
an excellent square for the night
uh you cannot trade knight for night
because you lose a piece and
otherwise uh you can just trade maybe
bishop for night but that's not
something you want to do this bishop is
an excellent piece
and you want to keep it there for as
long as possible and now there are some
10 games in the database that actually
reach this exact same position where
knights to b4 was played
challenging white slide square bishop
but here we have rooked the c8 by hikaru
and it is as a move tender we have a
completely new game
so let's see uh how the game continues
uh goes a3
now takes away the b4 square from uh
from the dark knight
and knight to e7 now shifting the knight
over to the king side
we have f4 now defending that nice uh
knight nicely twice and knights to f5
now
uh and here just queen to f3 everything
is nicely defended
uh and now queen to b6 with a double
attack on the d4 pawn
so obviously uh alireza needs to defend
it he does so by playing queen to f2
and now uh he carroll trades once on e5
he doesn't think this bishop will come
alive anytime soon so now he decides to
trade here bishop captures pawn captures
and now knight to g4 again attacking the
queen
and the queen needs to keep an eye on
the d4 square so queen to f4
and now just knight g to e3 with an
attack on the rook and also there's now
a double attack on the pawn on c2
so uh taking uh those things into
account to just rook
after c1 getting rid of both threats and
now comes the bishop to b5
and this is uh where our game really
gets really interesting here you could
do bishop captures on f5 it's of course
possible
but furujo goes for g4 and now what do
you do here your knight is under attack
so here uh he just decides uh hikaru
decides that
this is not a problem and he plays
bishop captures on d3
c captures and now knight the c2 just
attacking that
rook on a one uh but this is what furuja
wanted he wanted to create some sort of
a
an imbalance in the position and get an
attack going he goes g
captures on f5 now of course he's hoping
for something like uh
if if he gets f6 and queen to g5 in then
it's game over
so hikaru boldly grabs the rook knight
captures on a1
and now uh f6 is still too too early for
that if you go f6 now
then uh hikaru has this rook captures on
c1 with check and that
rook and c1 uh can could have been used
for the attack for example bishop
captures on c1
now you can capture here and after
captures just king h8 and the rook is
coming to g8 with tempo
so you will not have any any any checks
with checkmates following
so after knight captures on a1 rook
capture sunday one by ferruja and
now comes rook to c2 and this is a
critical position in the game here you
have to play f6 you cannot allow white
to play f6 because if white gets f6 in
black is just done for but hikaru for
some reason allows it he plays rook to
c2
and now uh uh ferruccio of course
immediately goes f6
and now what do you play here uh well
obviously you cannot go grabbing pieces
because if you capture just queen g5 and
that's a game over
uh nothing for you to do there even if
you even if you capture this with check
just king h1 and there there
there are no more checks this is just
happening and that's it g6
of course uh loses the queen to h6 and
still there there's no move here for for
black so here instead
after this uh uh f6 move we have
h6 by hikaru but just for fun uh we're
going to show what happens if the pawn
is captured if the pawn is captured
then comes queen to h6 and now king to
h1 and
rook to g1 are a big threat so here f5
uh and now comes king to h1 as planned
now comes
f6 making some room for the king to
escape here
but now e captures on f6 and it's going
to be an impossible position for black
to defend
you're going to have to go back rook c7
then comes rook g1 check
king f7 rook to g7 check and now it's
just uh
black's entire position is falling apart
uh so uh
instead of going for this uh we have h6
by hikaru
maybe this will be a sturdier defense uh
and now comes uh
king the h1 uh firuja prepares to bring
the rook over to g1
but again uh capturing on g7 is
perfectly fine uh for example if king
captures on g7
you have to play bishop to c1 but this
is incredibly hard to find but i will
show it
just because it's very interesting and
now not much you can do to defend this
for example queen c6 going after the
bishop here
knight the e for now and now the bishop
is defended twice and if you capture the
knight
then this is winning captures with check
king to g8 now queen g5 check
king goes to h8 queen h5 czech king goes
back and now bishop to h6
and there is no defense against the
czech and the mate
uh so instead after this knight the e4
move you cannot capture the knight you'd
have to go rook to h8 to defend the h6
pawn
but it doesn't matter knight to d6 now
with the attack on the f7 pawn and after
this is defended the king to h1
now the rook comes into the game king f8
you're gonna play bishop to e3 and now
after let's say rook h7 rook to f1
uh or even better queen to h4 and
there's uh
there's simply no no holding this for
black so it's a really
uh really terrible position uh for
hikaru so after this move uh like i said
uh you could capture
but we have kinked the h1 firoujo wants
to immediately bring the rook here
and now comes g5 attacking that queen
rook to g1 all the same since now you
cannot capture the queen
and rook f the c8 so again what do you
play here
queen to h4 is one possibility going
after the h6 pawn
furuja goes knight to f3 he wants the
bust open with knight captures on g5 and
hikaru says okay i'm just going to move
my king here so it doesn't come with any
checks
and now furuja just goes for it uh
knight captures and g5
queen upon characters and queen captures
and now uh this is the threat of
checkmate since the pawn
uh is preventing the king from escaping
to e7 so king the e8 this is a must
uh queen to g8 check king to d7 and now
queen captures on f7 with check king to
c6 if you go here it's
just a checkmate with the rook so that's
out of the question
so king has to run away queen captures
on e6 is happening
king to b5 and now queen captures on d5
so
furuja gobbles up all of he corresponds
and now he has
three connected past pawns here and also
a very nice attack the king is still in
king to a6 and we finally reach the
position from the thumbnail
there's only one move that wins this
position so it's
it's a very difficult move to find feel
free to pause the video and
try to win this position for white while
i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredibly difficult move to find and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
uh it's actually rook to g2 rook to g2
just uh not allowing any doubling up of
the rooks
on the second rank and also not allowing
any uh rook to h8 ideas
to drop on this pawn here and now once
you've prevented this everything is
nicely defended you cannot go rook to c1
uh there's not all that much for black
to do here and now white will have his
chance
of pushing those pawns and it will be it
will be a a very good game for white and
the black has to play
uh incredibly correct just to not lose
immediately
for example once a4 comes that queen is
stuck there you cannot allow queen to b5
it's uh it will be impossible to hold
this and of course if you capture the
rook for example rook capture so you're
going to play
king captures and even rook to c to
check king g3 you simply don't care
about this if rook
captures here you're just gonna play
queen to c for with check and that's it
uh king to a5 for example queen a for
checkmate
or you can go queen to b5 but you don't
really care
captures captures and now uh all
these pawns are of course winning just
f7 and the rook is not in time to
pick up the any of them so uh
this is what would have been best here
uh after this uh king to a6 move
uh this rook to g2 however it was an
incredibly hard move to find
uh and furuja decided to go for f7
instead
and now we have this position uh where
white uh
i mean it looks like white is perfectly
crushing it
but uh you know not all is as it seems
because here
uh black has a couple of ways to deal
with this position one of them is to go
rook to f2 you simply stop this pawn
and now it's a very quick draw by
repetition because you cannot allow rook
to seat you to
go after this pawn you'd have to block
it but now just rook to f1
check and we get a nice repetition here
so that's out of the question so after
f7 we have rook captures on b2 hikaru
now will
try to double up this way however here
we have
rook to f1 now furuja wants to advance
that
f7 pawn to victory but again there was
only
one move that saves the position for
white and that's a4
you have to play with those pawns those
pawns are
uh your only way of uh doing anything
here for example now rook c to c2
now you trade queens queen checks on b5
captures captures with
check king captures and now of course
you are threatening to bring the queen
into the game however
hikaru would be threatening checkmate so
first you have to prevent checkmate
uh give your king some breeding room and
then we would have another draw by
repetition rook we want check rook g1
then again you threaten checkmate white
has to block rugby one check blocks
and so on another uh draw by threefold
repetition
so after this rook captures on b2 uh
furuja
goes rook to f1 instead and now it's a
problem hikaru goes to rook c to c2
immediately
and first brings a queen into the game
queen
queen to f8 um now there are two queens
on the board for white
but it's actually a checkmate in three
for hikaru so
once again feel free to pause the video
and win this game for hikaru
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
sequence
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's rook captures an h2 with
check king g1 and now of course you
cannot go rook here with checkmate
because the queen covers that but
not a problem queen to g6 check it's uh
amazing how that queen wiggles out
uh you know in between the the two white
queens but they are powerless to stop uh
uh the attack now you have to go queen
to g2
uh you were so very happy that you were
covering that square but now
not so much and here of course captures
or captures would be checkmate
so for example captures here uh would be
checkmate
uh so yeah uh but the game didn't
continue after queen to g6 check
uh first resigned and an excellent uh
win for hikaru who
who took a a four to two lead after this
after this game
uh so yeah uh thanks once again to rimbo
for suggesting this game it was a
quite a brutal game and it's always
funny like this is a bullet game one
plus one okay not
not uh the the super bullet uh but still
so many
possibilities and so many things that
could have happened in a bullet game is
just uh i mean
it's uh incredible uh so yeah it all
came down to this after this king to a6
move
uh furuja had to find rook to g2 but i
mean look at this position you have a
you have your bishop stuck on b2 black
is threatening to capture it you have
ideas like a4 maybe maybe trading the
queen right away
you have ideas of pushing those past
pawns you have i mean who who thinks of
rook to g2 it's uh not a move i i think
would
have been easily found in in larger time
formats let alone in
in a bullet game uh but yeah you were
you know
in the comfort of your own home so
perhaps you you were able to solve it
and if you had once again
congratulations uh so yeah that's uh the
game i hope you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank uh abdel traore
matt o'brien rafael ferreira uh marvin
sparrow and brian gura for contribution
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions such as
this one
and whatever else happens in the chess
world thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day